this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's going to be checking
out the bizarre weapons of death loop a
game that's full of crazy guns that
nearly broke our poor jonathan so we're
taking our two recoilless double barrel
pistols and we're sticking one up the
other one for once of a better phrase
that is
insanity
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
[Music]
this thing is nuts i haven't really got
a frame of reference for it except for
this
so guns with two magazines basically the
only thing that this has in common
with this thing the reason i've grabbed
it is it has this very funky
dual magazine effectively two magazines
welded together but um it
duplicates the functionality of this gun
in that it has two positions you fire
the first magazine then you press up on
this this catch here which realistically
means moving your finger
of your firing hand to this position you
then push the whole arrangement across
and then you
fire your second magazine so enough of
the real world let's look at this thing
so what we've got are a sort of double
decker arrangement of magazines here and
an auto eject feature so so when one
magazine runs dry the gun automatically
ejects it from the weapon auto ejecting
magazines are not a thing generally you
need to retain your magazine lessen an
emergency
the logic here seems to be that you can
keep up you can keep ammunition in the
gun a bit like topping up a pump action
or a lever action by shoving in a fresh
mag whenever an empty one pops out which
leads to this slight this slightly
comedic reloading animation of just
magazines popping out the gun and you
slap another one in and another one pops
out you slap another one in i like it
it's
interesting gameplay-wise because it
does allow you to sustain fire which i
suspect is why they've toned down the
rate of fire for what this thing would
do i admire them for essentially not
caring at all about mechanics and how
this would actually work where's the
bolt in this thing how is ammunition
from the bottom magazine being fed at
all nobody knows and i imagine i'm about
the only person who cares as well
another interesting design the so-called
four pounder i assume because in real
life it would weigh four pounds because
it is a big old chunk of steel and it
kind of looks futuristic it almost looks
like the blade runner blaster was
combined with a bergmann and a luger
because it does have the mass a massive
set of toggle ears on top of it and it's
toggle operated although i don't quite
know how there's no obvious
way that this would function the toggle
does pop up out of the gun i assume
there's meant to be a bolt that's
reciprocating within the frame a little
unclear as to how that would actually
function the little magazine sort of
belies the
power of this thing it does say
ammunition large caliber the magazine
housing looks relatively small i don't
know if they've worked out there space
and dimensions there i've only just
noticed the the muzzle on this thing is
in line with the trigger it's very low
that makes it mechanically even less
plausible than i thought actually so
this is possibly inspired by partly by
mataiba maybe by the chiappa rhino a
couple of designs where the barrel lines
up with the lower chamber on a cylinder
now this isn't cylinder operated it's
operated by a magazine so how that
magazine can possibly feed
where the chamber is located any of that
that there is absolutely no concession
to engineering here at all that i can
see rule of cool
rules
this game is blowing my tiny little mind
so what's on the face of it a
conventional looking lever action
shotgun i probably would have guessed
but it also fires
canisters of goo with a very audible
breaking glass sound effect that you can
somehow hear over the report of the
firearm
and then what really
is strange is
the transforming nature of the thing i'm
not sure why you need to transform the
receiver and barrel and everything of
the gun in order to turn it into a
conventional buckshot firing shotgun and
if you did need to do that why it would
end up looking like some sort of robot
mess in that mode if anything i'd expect
it to look conventional in the shotgun
mode and turn into something wacky to
shoot canisters of whatever so it's a
little counter-intuitive in that respect
as is the fact that it is a lever action
what it boils down to is that this thing
is
mechanically complex to achieve its
transforming function if it's that
mechanically complex and powered somehow
why can't you use that to load the next
cartridge why would you need an external
lever and it comes down to because it
looks cool and because we want to do the
terminate 2
john wayne 1887 shotgun flip
uh which to the credit of the game is in
there um you can't have a flamboyant
lever action gun like this and not do
the uh spin cocking so i totally approve
of that but this is an extremely
confusing design from anything other
than an artistic standpoint
light infantry machine pistol
why do i know this
oh
okay
okay for the sake of my sanity i'm very
glad that we've uh moved to something
relatable i suppose would be the word to
use so this thing is
clearly a take on the vz861 scorpion
machine pistol submachine gun or in this
case the one i've just grabbed to remind
you what a scorpion looks like is
actually a very rare prototype
semi-automatic version so the idea here
was you would have a specific variant of
the normally fully automatic scorpion
that was self-loading only
for use as
more of a sidearm now having said that
apart from the wire stock and the
general configuration this thing is
actually quite different they've gone
back to the drawing board literally and
they've come up with this quite
intriguing curve curved look to the
thing it's got well a number of
departures from the scorpion so whereas
the scorpion's got these two little
button
cocking is on here this thing has a sort
of ak style cocking handle definite
attention to detail here we see where
we're going at kimbo the player actually
reaches under to [ __ ]
the cocking handle that he can't
access with his firing hand because he's
using both of them so we may not be
adhering to real world firearms here in
any way but we are adding to how things
biomechanics essentially how the human
body relates to machinery
there's a lot to say about this one i
think
my first impression was
maybe uh
mg0815 first world war german machine
gun with sort of aircraft cooling like
turning the water jacket into a not a
water jacket by cutting lots of holes in
it which is what they did for aircraft
maxim gun use but actually this is a
multi-barreled gun with like a heat
shield around
the cluster of rotating barrels but a
very slow rate of fire for a
multi-barreled gun and one of the
advantages of a multi-barrel gun is a
high rate of fire
and cooling that allows you to maintain
that high rate of fire not so here
though because the way the mechanism
works however it works in detail because
i can't tell you there would only be one
bolt here because there's not a rotating
that the barrel cluster does not rotate
with its own cluster of bolts like a
gallon gun mini gun vulcan so this is
kind of pointlessly multi-barreled which
would add weight and not much else the
sights are really strange we've got a
very large rear aperture and then
somehow the the front sight that almost
looks like an anti-aircraft site in its
own right perched out on the end of the
cooling jacket pops up when you shoulder
it which i cannot understand if the if
the gun had a an optical sight as
standard and there was a button for the
flip up front sight and that would sort
of make sense but then the rear sight's
always there so why would you have a
pop-up front sight and at that point my
brain melts except it hasn't finished
yet because that front sight if you look
at the model is mounted about two inches
below the rear sight so how does the
front sight even align with the rear
sight and now now the brain has
gone home
another very interesting design i can
best compare this to a break open
hunting rifle of the late 19th or early
20th century in keeping with what
increasingly seems almost a sort of
alternate cold war era so we don't have
much in the way of accessories or iron
sights but we do have quite streamlined
looking high-tech firearms it almost
looks like an air rifle in its
aesthetic but then in the actual use of
the thing it's got that authoritative
sound and operation
much more like it's um probable
inspiration the
big game rifle it's got a thumb brake
lever on the top which is again a
feature of a sporting rifle for some
reason it operates the opposite way a
break open gun for a right-hander the
lever operates to the right um here it
operates to the left and he's actually
doing it with his or she is actually
doing it with his left hand which is
slightly awkward normally you would
assist the gun open with your left hand
and operate the lever with your right
hand so this is a little bit funky
giving you a two-stage operation of open
lever break open and they're kind of
alluding to the manual force you need to
apply to a manually operated weapon to
get it to extract and eject as is
typical with games there is no visible
extractor or ejector mechanism it just
kind of magically pumps out of the
breach into the air
[Applause]
this is a good example of what i think
of as the decorative scope reticle so we
have a very svd-esque range estimation
bit in the corner we've got windage like
graticule across the across the middle
and we've got weird semicircular stuff
at the top it's a very busy looking
scope none of which is functional as far
as i can tell in this game it's just
there to look snipery that's this isn't
a criticism it's just
an observation that we know that a scope
should look busy and high-tech and as
though a lot of thought has to be put
into the shot but gameplay-wise we're
not prepared to put that thought into it
we just want to make the heads go boom
uh the name's interesting uh sapocura
seems to be a play on latin for burial
effectively i don't know what pratera
means it almost looks portuguese but i
don't think it is i'm guessing that's
meant to be a brand name or something or
maybe the whole thing is a brand name
don't know very um creative naming along
with all the other creative decisions
taken in in this game
useful for redecorating
or silent head shots with pneumatic
prejudice
we have ourselves a nail gun like even
the character here is suggesting that
it's a repurposed decorating tool it
does have a form of iron sights on it
now those could just be for a lining for
a to get your nail in straight that's
probably what those are in theory meant
to be but what they do allow you to do
is to aim a shot at distance which of
course
if the thing is powerful enough would
make it usable as an improvised weapon
which is what's happening the reload is
a little bit comedy with the open up the
lid dropping the handful of nails yeah
convenient topping up of the nails is
convenient for a tool of course just
like a magazine of rounds is for a
firearm but i would imagine you would at
least have them all facing the same way
and maybe in some sort of a clip uh nail
guns usually work on some sort of strip
feed because you like her cartridge you
need to align it at least with the point
forward so that seems a little
optimistic to me as to how you would
automatically sort them so they're
facing the right way and don't instantly
jam the gun
hey
this this one has pretty much broken me
i'll be honest guys
again we've got two magazines this time
we've got two barrels so it could work
but there are no holes in the magazines
from whence the cartridges might emerge
in order to feed into the chamber so i
can only conclude that this thing
feeds through sheer force of will
because i can't there's no there's no
room in the receiver for them to come
out of the bottom of the magazines it's
a shotgun of some kind
turret slash pan drum mags for a shotgun
seems like a bad idea even if there what
was a way to get them to come out of the
drum yeah there's
zero concerns were given during the
design of these firearms in terms of
realism
[Music]
i can see the word transform so
something wacky is going to happen so
let's just look at how these things are
working right now before i lose the
world to live these are the handguns
they have through and through barrels
like a recoilless weapon and there is
exhaust slash propellant gas or possibly
rocket exhaust coming out of the back of
a pair of over and under barrels so on
the face of it these are gyrojet style
rocket pistols but instead of just
containing the initial recoil the
initial
launch of the mini rockets
yeah it doesn't quite make sense what it
seems to be it's not so much a gyro jet
it's more of a one-handed recoilless
weapon let's see how deep the rabbit
hole goes
and the answer is pretty damn deep that
is insanity so we're taking our two
recoilless double barrel pistols and
we're sticking one up the other one for
once of a better phrase they are then
converting themselves and firing a
string of shots so effectively a pistol
becomes as it said in the menu actually
now that i recall converting from pistol
to submachine gun i kind of thought each
one would convert rather than like
voltron style
combining them together so we've got
we've got enough exhaust ports here for
for these for back blast from handgun
rounds what what isn't clear is how we
go from two
barrels
to
three rounds going off at once so almost
like there's a third barrel has inserted
itself between the other two barrels and
is exhausting out of the back as well
there's something else going on here
that is beyond
human imagination
[Music]
i've i've almost i'm almost speechless
on this one not because it's super wacky
or anything i mean you could design a
pistol that looked like that and
functioned look at the whitney wolverine
for example for a sort of 30s flash
gordon take on on this kind of layout
there's a hint of the luger of the p-38
about it but it's i don't think it's
based on anything i think they've come
up with an original design some sort of
self-loading mechanism goes punting out
the back when you shoot it but as is
becoming a bit of a theme i can't really
see how it would work although i think
you could make it work it's conventional
as far as this game goes
[Music]
i think this is an excellent example of
real world firearms engineering design
history all of that versus
what you can do in a video game on the
face of it this is a very conventional
pump action shotgun but in detail the
pump action literally looks too short
for the cartridge length you have to be
able to get that bolt far enough to the
rear for the gun to actually cycle this
looks very short quite an interesting
jam there so this thing has a great big
dust cover slash ejection door thing on
the right hand side of it that has to
pop open every time the gun is cycled
which in theory would keep out dirt and
stuff that you don't want getting in the
gun but there's a reason why generally
dust covers are either open or shut on
guns they don't close and open between
shots usually because it just adds
another layer of complexity and
potentially unreliability we saw a
stoppage there a failure to
eject where the very cartridge-shaped
door unsurprisingly retained the
cartridge case on its way out the gun
and if you were to try and make this gun
for real that's one of the many issues
that i think you would encounter now
rather than use a hand to open that door
and assist the cartridge case out as
we'd expect with a real stoppage the
player in the true spirit of this game
simply slaps it on the opposite side
until the door opens enough for the case
to come flying out not the most
practical way to clear a stoppage but it
it fits somehow
[Music]
as always we will be back
next time and over on the armory's
youtube channel you can watch our series
on
usually pretty weird guns from the
armories collection we've got links in
the description as always for donations
and you can go from check out our
social media our shop and anything else
that takes your fancy thanks guys see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you